john clayton reported earlier this week
that the raiders
are very interested in steelers receiver
juju smith schuster
look the steelers have plenty of depth
the position a lot of money it's going
to take to keep him around he's not a
true number one but peter i think that
the juju would be the perfect nelson
aguilar replacement for the raiders the
perfect compliment to henry ruggs
because we've seen what juju can do
when the other guy's getting double
covered
why do you need to replace nelson
aguilera
don't know he's on a one-year deal maybe
he's going to move on maybe they think
juju is an upgrade i remember there was
that story from a few weeks ago from i
think vic tafer of the athletic that
aguilar
blew a gasket on his teammates after the
loss to the dolphins
justifiably but it may make you wonder
whether or not he fits in the plans but
uh uh look somebody's gonna pay maybe it
makes you think maybe it makes john
gruden and mike mayak think we need more
nelson aguilars that that may be the
case
uh maybe the cleveland browns would sign
juju smith schuster because after all
the browns
is the browns as juju said that may be
his parting shot
coming back all right that's one of the
changes that could happen in pittsburgh
a lot of changes coming today's draft
teams that will look a lot different in
2021
peter i'll give you the first pick
look i'm going to take jacksonville
because they will be the most different
looking franchise
in the nfl not just because they're
taking trevor lawrence
but because i think when you have a new
coach
that is intending to put his stamp on
every corner of the organization
you know who's making all of the hires
in the organization
who's bringing in all the free agents
when you do that
when you do that you basically set
yourself up
to go from 1 in 15
to wherever but you're going to
you know implode the 1 in 15 and you're
gonna say okay
who's good here miles jack okay miles
jack you're staying
everybody else we're not so sure see you
after
uh you know after mini camps so to me i
think jacksonville would be number one
for me
i agree with you there the next one same
division the houston texans they're
going to be so different they may as
well
peel the logo off the helmet and get a
graphic of jack easter be doing stand-up
comedy because
that's his team now and it's been
reshaped
in his warped and twisted image of what
a football team should be
with or without deshawn watson that team
is going to look a lot different in 2021
peter
detroit lions i'll take the lions
because i really want to see bitten off
kneecaps
i've never seen that football game
before so
i want to see that number one but number
two
i want to try i want to see if uh the
new quarterback
can be salvaged all right i think i
think that
and the other part of detroit that is so
interesting to me
is i really think aaron glenn within two
or three years
he's going to be a head coach in the nfl
he is going to put his mark on that
defense
and he is going to be a bold play caller
and play designer on defense
in the todd bowles mold so i think
detroit is going to look very different
i've got to go with the saints even if
the only change is at quarterback when
you've had drew brees as your
quarterback since 2006
it's dramatically different to go
forward without him and he's undoubtedly
retiring he did that contract adjustment
25 million dollar salary down to 1
million
with no quid pro quo he's making it
easier for his
exit to be processed from a cap
standpoint and even then
they got to do a lot of work they're
going to have to let some guy go the
guys go they will be different
because of the cap crunch this year so
on top of drew brees being gone
other guys are going to be gone sean
payton's going to have his work cut out
for him in 2021 peter
my next choice is going to be the
philadelphia eagles um
it's just you know mike it was
exactly three years ago last week
that doug peterson was the philly
special
miracle worker the offensive staff was
was the brightest offensive staff in
football
nick foles was had the best
pinch-hitting job
in nfl history and they had their
franchise quarterback
coming back in carson wentz this was
going to be
a model franchise for the future so
three years later
doug peterson uh is fired
and they think so much of them that in
16 minutes
in announcing his successor jeffrey
lurie doesn't even mention his name
um it's it's an odd odd situation
and now this week next week whenever
um when the when the kitty gets pushed
to the middle of the table
and everyone is anted in uh probably
carson wentz is gone too
chicago indy the number one and two
contenders for him but now you have to
look at the philadelphia eagles
and basically say all right
so if you went to vegas last year at
this time
how much money would you have bet that
the coaching quarterback of the eagles
what odds could you have gotten would be
nick ciriani and jalen hurts
i mean those would be fairly long odds
that would be like
peter king modeling for nutrasystem uh
this coming year
but but anyway i just think the eagles
are going to look incredibly different
plus because of all their cap
issues they're going to look incredibly
different when football starts again on
late after labor day weekend
i thought you were going to go with the
kramer comparison say peter king
modeling for calvin klein underwear
so uh that would have been much better
next one for me i got to go with the
patriots here
because we know there's going to be a
new starting quarterback
we assume there will be the cam newton
thing didn't work the way that it was
supposed to jarrett stidham i don't
think is the answer brian hoyer is
definitely not the answer and they got
to do
something i they got to do something to
answer what tom brady did and i know
bill belichick
may resist just for the sake of saying
i'm not going to get desperate i'm not
going to go all in
i'm not going to try to make a major
upgrade well you better because you know
who's coming to town
at some point during the 2021 season
it's tom brady in the buccaneers
you better be ready for that one you
better make sure
that it's not like rocky fighting ivan
drago in russia
where the crowd during the fight turns
on they're gonna go for tommy
if you don't have a team on the field
that can compete with him
yeah can we have a bonus one on this one
mike do you think
yes okay so i realize
you didn't you didn't take the jets
but in my opinion they may
they may uh beat everybody in how
different that they look
because obviously a new head coach i
think they're gonna have a new
quarterback
and mike with two ones if they don't
have to get rid of them
can you imagine if they get the oregon
tackle
you know with with the second pick
overall and then worry about the
quarterback down the road
just in the back of my mind i'm thinking
okay
they're gonna have the best tackle
situation in football
you know after taking beckton and then
pinay sewell or i always pronounce his
name wrong
and then what if they take trey lance
you know with their other first round
pick
if they're able to do that i mean this
is a
totally fascinating franchise you don't
know what they're going to do at
quarterback
they've got four ones the next two years
they've got a new head coach who's going
to bring in
a new way of doing things all around the
building
i think the jets are going to look
plenty different i'm torn here you know
it's easy to say the rams because we
know there's going to be a different
quarterback and matthew stafford for
jared goff is a huge difference but i'm
going to go with the steelers we don't
know yet how it's going to manifest
itself but the steelers are going to
look
very different because of the cap
they're one of the few teams in the nfl
that is always bumping up against the
cap they're always redoing contracts to
kick money into future years
the reckoning is coming this any type of
a deal with ben roethlisberger that's
going to allow him to come back ed
bouchette of the athletics suggested
within the last week or two that's still
not guaranteed to happen they still may
not
find the right middle ground but between
james connor juju smith schuster
i think a lot of potential changes bud
dupree likely gone after tearing his acl
in a franchise tagged year
a lot of changes for the steelers team a
lot of pressure on the steelers next
year peter
uh and and uh i still think there's a
chance they're gonna go in a different
direction at quarterback
i mean they should definitely think
about it i think pittsburgh when we're
doing this show a year from now
pittsburgh will be the number one draft
choice
wow wow because they will have earned it
no i don't mean they're going to have
the number one draft choice i mean
in this segment what teams are going to
change the most this year
well and and i'm not a big fan of this
one more year with a quarterback thing
and if
roethlisberger's talking like one more
year the team's talking like one more
year
maybe it's time to move on hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports